yeah man I'm drove on my colleagues
Ville and Chico and during this time
we're going to take a look at some of
the amigo functionality that folks to
look forward to in legend of zelda
breath of the wild that's right so as as
everybody recalls we release the legend
zelda twilight princess with wolf league
legends of Twilight Princess HD on wii u
came bundled with a wolf link amiibo
which you see right here and at the time
we mentioned that the game would have
amoeba would have functionality in the
legend zelda for wii u then we you now
breath of the wild and so we wanted to
take the opportunity today to show you
what the amoeba is going to do in game
and so we want to start with a quick
video just recapping how the amoeba
function in Twilight Princess HD
so we're going to cut to that video
really quickly and and show you if you
recall with what it does there but
essentially the way that it worked in
that video is you would enter the cave
of shadows as wolf link when you tapped
it in and you would play the challenges
in there and you would complete the cave
of shadows and then you would tap the
amoeba to the Wii U gamepad and it would
save the number of remaining parts that
you had in the after completing the cave
of shadows to the wolf link amiibo and
so now what we want to do is we're going
to actually tap this to the to Wii the
Wii U version of Zelda breath of the
wild and show you what it does so as you
see you use one of your runes there on
the sheikah slate to give you access to
via meebo and we tap it in
no let's see oh there I heard a little
oh we have a slight tech up there we go
you may have seen a little effect
they're similar to what you see in
Twilight Princess tapping the Amigo to
the Wii U gamepad in breadth of the wild
will bring wolf link into the game as a
partner character so we've been showing
you a lot of the game we've been showing
you running around and exploring / house
what you've noticed is that link does
not have a partner character in the game
and that is true typical of a Zelda game
you would normally see somebody like an
a B or in the case of Twilight Princess
amid nut and the case of breath of the
while link is generally exploring alone
and so if you do want that partner
character you would tap in the wolf link
amiibo and call wolf link in both linked
as a variety of different things in the
game in addition to just kind of being a
partner character that runs around with
you as you can see here wolf link helps
with combat he will actually attack
enemies and and will help you fight them
PFC crosswind
yeah it's really cute when he does he
kind of like hunkers down and growls a
little bit the other thing that's the
other thing that's really cool is you do
looking at how big he is you're like
yeah that's that's linked crouch down in
wolf's eyes oh there we go now apart
from from combat the other thing that
wolf link will do is if you get close
enough to to a wild animal Oh looks like
you need to get a little bit closer
there chica wolf wolf link will go out
and hunt the animal for you he's able to
sense prey since meat and he'll help you
out with that as well go for a comfy no
he doesn't just to me you can see the
animation also just really fluid really
nice chain a little bit as a boss yeah
he still has the chain around his paw
from when he was in prison at the
beginning of twilight princess
oh there he goes ah oh there you go
there you go he got better got that bore
right there on the rump and took them
down for you Chico it totally impossible
easy especially in combat with large of
enemies of a powerful it's really
interesting to see how
that's right now we also have from the
show floor here at e3 one of the things
that we're showing obviously we've got a
meebo on display here on the show floor
one of the things that we're showing is
the what the process is we're creating a
meebo it starts very very simply with a
very basic 3d printed model usually
these are based off of some of the
in-game models that we see in the game
and and so in this case wolfling started
off with this very basic gray in game
model and if you if you're able to get
up close on that you can see sort of the
illegal polygonum nature of the print
here I think perhaps a little bit later
in the day we may have a chance to to
show the full process but there's sort
of about five different steps in the
creation process before we actually end
up getting to the final model here yes
interesting I think some fun stuff for
the shade how much iteration goes into
the creation of via meebo but when
you're looking at some characters from
certain games their physical structure
might make it really channel
to make amiibo especially religious
ballads and making sure that you've got
them in a pose that they're going to
have nice stability when you've actually
got them let's say sitting on a shelf or
you're playing with them that's right
and in fact you you start with this
basic 3d model print and then from there
you have to refine the model itself and
then you get into sort of once you
finalize that model then you start to
get into some test painting and things
like that and it becomes so it's
actually a very long process it takes
start to finish it can take upwards of
roughly you know ten months to a year
from the very beginning of the amoeba
creation process until the actual
product launches so it actually is a
long process but one that's fun to watch
and see oh go through all those
different forms especially the poses get
refine I do I've seen certain iterations
for some of our nebo where they're
really experimenting with how best to
pose the character of positions or
through its meat seeing kind of what
didn't work as well in a different test
cases that they do
that's right now going back to wolf link
in the game we mentioned that when you
tap wolf weekend he will have the number
of hearts that you saved in Twilight
Princess and he'll he'll travel
alongside you for the duration of your
gameplay and he'll do this until he
loses all of his hearts fortunately
Chico is doing a good job here and is
taking good care of wolf link and so he
hasn't taken a whole lot of damage yet
but once those hearts run out then wolf
link will disappear and the next time
you know if you do want to play with him
again then you can wait one day in
real-world time not one day an in-game
time but one day in real-world time and
then you can tap wolf link to the
gamepad again and call him back into
breath of the wild you need to get after
those boys do you know how interesting
what a difference wolfling can make
especially if you've taken the time to
really kind of make him up really wolf
before you bring him into the game and
if you're starting out he can really
help cover your back for you as you're
getting a flop game he was right behind
me oh well that's the other thing you
can do is you can he can't be down any
of them it's so kind of him Eddie he
takes down the prey but does not eat the
meat he leaves that for you he loves me
now the other thing of course is if you
do get separated from wolf link you can
you can blow your whisk you can blow a
whistle or whistle to him and call him
back to you and you'll also of course to
use a wolf oh listen to that bark I love
it a lot of a really cool conditions
watch it so good oh so you can a few
runs off in a different direction then
you can whistle to him and he'll come
back to you look at all about his
ability to sniff things out as well well
yeah you will of course he is a wolf so
wolves having good noses he'll be able
to help you out and later on in the game
and be able to sniff out certain items
for you which is quite nice but of
course wolf link isn't the only amoeba
that's going to be compatible with the
legend of zelda breath of the wild talk
about this interesting we actually have
a few more brand new amoeba hopefully we
can get in very close on these the level
of detail on these new amoeba are really
truly stunning this is Archer link and
I'm just going to slowly rotate him
around especially the detail on the back
of the shows this side you can see right
here you can see the detail on the
chicest late the the head of this arrow
which you see from the video in the
Guardian battle incredibly detailed very
very well replicated you have the arrows
hanging from from leaks belt and and
just the amount of detail that you get
on even his arm bands and tunic are
really amazing these are easily the most
highly detailed an EVO that I think
we've created so far and and this is the
first of we have three that we want to
show you today so the first is Archer
link and really cool I can't wait to get
these it's great because I've been you
know Allen amazon I've been talking for
a long time about wanting to to have
Zelda figures available for people so
hopefully people are excited for these
this is writer link again
yeah the just the sense of presence you
get from the horse the way that it
sculpted you get so much detail on the
muscles the main even the the bridle
with the saddle and everything links
shield hanging on the back the
saddlebags really really nice we have
some online we have some videos that
show these in really close up detail
rotating around that are really great
look we got these on display actually at
the booth here so folks can maybe check
out hopefully they'll be some more
photos hope you're taking online but
it's so impressive how they were able to
realize the art style I think of the
game here and it really feels to get
captures the like the softness of the
color and the detail it's a likely
always probably the only few people if
we can actually touch it I know yeah I'm
not like my job Rigby these are these
are still in a prototype form there near
final but that they are because of that
they're a little bit fragile still I
feel like you've been worried that if
something terrible happens man but
keeping a very respected of that one
more to show us and this one is of
course very very impressive this is a
guardian amiibo and again you can see
the amount of detail it really helps to
bring sort of those glowing pink colors
to life you can see the eye in front
there and although i'm not going to not
going to bend it today this is the first
an EVO that we've created that has
poseable parts you can bend the leg
if you're with our pre-production model
it's you happen it very careful so I'd
rather not but in the when we release
this alongside the game you'll be able
to bend the legs freely and kind of pose
the amoeba however you like kind of
looking forward to making dioramas with
his arms like he's going to be grabbing
other and evil in my collection or maybe
actually battling leak or something I've
got him sitting out is because you're
really fun to see what I can do once
I've got a production bottle like you
feel safer yeah so these are three amigo
that we have coming to launch alongside
divisions elbow breath of the wild and
I'm really excited I can't wait to get
them but we just wanted to give you a
quick moment and share those with you
Chico is there anything else that you
wanted to show us with wolf link or we
could maybe do some quick running around
with and maybe see if we can find
another camp to hit before you wrap up I
think there's a
here I hope their wake we don't want to
always you know what and when they're
sleeping it is really interesting i
found just finding new places to run
around with in that and actually might
be coming up to something that we
shouldn't see just yet so alright well
hang onto that for later but thank you
so much bill and Chico for joining us
and giving us a look at the amoeba
functionality folks again if you have
any news videos here at the show you
might want to see if they can take some
photos reason we've got them on display
and please don't go anywhere afternoon
next up we're gonna cause me motifs on
join us and we're going to be talking
about how this game expertise in a
really interesting range the original
Legend of Zelda zone so please stay
tuned we'll be right back